this video is kindly sponsored by
morning brew
the free daily newsletter find out more
later in the video
hey 42 here by the mid-19th century
america was caught in the grip of
pioneer fever spreading her
star-spangled wings across the land
gobbling up new territories and laying
claim to new regions
brothers george and jacob donna found
themselves swept up in this allure of
untouched far away lands so
along with their families they upped
sticks and set off
on the 2 500 mile journey
from springfield illinois to california
in search of the prosperity and wealth
that the american west promised the
donors were joined by the reed family
headed by james reid who'd recently
declared bankruptcy
and hoped to change his fortunes in
california
as an interesting side note reid was
good friends with a certain
mr abraham lincoln it's thought that
lincoln himself
seriously considered joining greed on
the long journey to the west
but instead opted to stay behind in the
hope of carving out a career
in politics which apparently went quite
well
in spite of his recent money troubles
james reid and his family
arrived at the start of the journey in a
specially built wagon
in what could be considered a hyper
early pilot for
mtv's pimp my ride this
custom double decker wagon came complete
with
shock absorbing seats bunk beds
and a cooking stove before morning brew
i used to spend my morning scrolling
through various social media
aimlessly looking for something to
stimulate my sleepy neurons
but i often find myself looking at the
same monotonous news as the day before
now with morning brew i can be up to
date with all the latest business
tech and finance news in just 5 minutes
morning brew is just the perfect way to
start your day
there's no dense and tedious articles
just
relevant informative updates written in
a refreshing
and witty narrative the newsletter is
delivered daily from monday
through to sunday meaning i'm reading
new content day to day
just recently on morning brew i learned
that el salvador
plans to make bitcoin legal tender
within the country
which would be the first nation to
formally adopt cryptocurrency
as part of its economy very interesting
so if you're interested in business tech
or finance like i am
then there's really no reason not to
subscribe to morning brew
it's completely free and takes less than
15 seconds
and to make it even easier you can just
click the link in the description below
to subscribe today anyone wanting to
travel to california
knew that reaching the sierra nevada
before winter
was vitally important if you wanted to
make it through the mountain range
and into the promised land arrive too
late
and the mountains would be impossible to
traverse
although the donners and reeds were
setting off a little late in the season
they'd still given themselves plenty of
time to reach their destination
just so long as nothing went wrong along
the way
spoiler alert everything totally went
wrong
the first 250 miles of the journey
passed by with relative ease
and the pioneers arrived in independence
missouri
the launch pad of the oregon trail on
schedule
after taking a few days to stock up on
supplies and
mentally prepare themselves for the epic
journey ahead
the two families pushed on west where
they joined up with a larger train of
some 50 wagons
so far things were going swimmingly and
both the donners and
reeds could have been forgiven for
thinking this wagoning halfway across a
continent business
was just a walk in the park but then
one by one things started to go
wrong unusually high water levels in the
big blue river
in what is today part of kansas but was
then simply
unorganized territory forced the group
to build rafts
and float their wagons across it it was
about this time
that the epic journey claimed its first
victim
not that shoddy raftsmanship had
anything to do with it
james reed's mother died of a
long-standing illness
still as fair as omens went it was a
fairly crappy one
whilst these setbacks were unfortunate
it was james reed's choice of reading
material
that really set the group on their path
towards infamy
you see he'd had his nose in a book
called
the emigrant's guide to oregon and
california
written by a mountaineer by the name of
lansford hastings
hastings was widely regarded as the man
in the know when it came to the oregon
trail
he saw himself as a kind of founding
father of california
and he encouraged as many people as
possible to make the journey there
in his book hastings mapped out a
shortcut
which he claimed would shave off a good
400 miles from the journey
james reid was quite taken by the idea
of
lopping a big chunk of miles off the
arduous journey ahead
believing that taking the so-called
hastings cutoff
could see the group arrive in california
a whole
month early even when an experienced
mountaineer
named james climan warned him that
he would do better to stick to the known
route
reed's faith in hastings shortcut was
unwavering
to say that faith was misplaced
would be a bit of an understatement you
see despite
literally writing the book on it
lansford hastings
had never actually taken his own
shortcut
sure he'd had a bit of a scout around
and hiked a few bits and pieces
but from there it seems he made the
rather interesting decision to assume
the rest of the shortcut hundreds of
miles of
unforgiving american wilderness was
probably fine what could possibly go
wrong
when james reid proposed a shortcut to
the rest of the group
plenty of the wagoners felt that
sticking to the tried and tested route
was probably their best bet but a fair
few
quite fancied the idea of arriving in
california
a bit earlier than planned so the group
was split into
two those that elected to take the
traditional trail
and those that decided to brave the
hastings cutoff
you've probably heard the saying he who
dares wins
but as we're about to find out sometimes
he who dares not only loses
he also ends up getting turned into
sausages
by his family and friends but i'm
getting ahead of myself
the group that chose the traditional
trail went on to arrive in california
unscathed if this video was about them
it would probably end around this point
thanks for watching
and you would probably be considering
unsubscribing right about now
the group that chose reed's proposed
shortcut however
had a much more exciting experience in
store for them
the group who chose the hastings cutoff
are known today
as the donna party that might sound like
the kind of thing that happens when
drunk people congregate in a kebab shop
after a night out
but the reality of the donna party was
surprisingly enough
even more terrifying the donner party
were given an early boost when they were
informed
lansford hastings himself was waiting
further along the trail
to personally guide any immigrants who
wish to take his proposed shortcut
to california unfortunately
by the time they arrived at fort bridger
a key resupply point on the oregon trail
where hastings was supposed to be
waiting
they discovered he'd already gone on
ahead with another wagon train
undeterred the group decided to continue
on with their plan
but when they reached the weber river in
what is now utah
they found a note left by hastings
informing all wagon trains
that an integral part of his shortcut
the weber canyon
was rather inconveniently utterly
impassable
hastings left directions for an
alternate route
but confidence in the shortcut was
beginning to wane
reed possibly starting to feel a little
worried
that he'd led the donner party into a
bit of a pickle
jumped on his horse and raced along the
trail to catch up with hastings
and ask him just what the hell was going
on
hastings a short read that everything
would be just
fine and that his new route would work
out just as well as the last one would
have done
if mother nature hadn't pulled a fast
one and plunked an impassable canyon
smack in the middle of it reed returned
to the group
full of optimism but before long
it became clear that surprise surprise
the new route was much more difficult
than hastings had actually promised
in fact it was so grueling the pioneers
were forced to cut down
trees as they went to clear a path for
the wagons
progress was glacial and by the time
they'd escaped the dense woodland
and reached the great salt lake desert
there was barely a month left of summer
time
was no longer on their side as is quite
typical of deserts
the great salt lake desert was big and
hot and generally quite keen on killing
any humans
stupid enough to enter it the donner
party ran out of water
within three days in the blistering heat
whilst by nights the temperature dropped
to freezing
to make matters even worse moisture
hidden beneath the
salt crust would rise during the day
turning the ground into a kind of
salt-flavored
glue pulling the wagons on this became
so difficult that many of the oxen
decided
they'd had enough of life on the trail
and made a run for it during the night
36 oxen were lost in total
and four wagons were abandoned the
desert
turned out to be twice as long as
hastings had told them
what the pioneers thought would take two
days
had taken five and by the time they
reached the other side
they no longer had enough food and water
to reach california the group was forced
to spend the next
week recovering beneath nearby pilot
peak
whilst two of their number rode ahead in
search of provisions
over a month after they set off on the
shortcut they finally rejoined the
traditional route
the cutoff had added 125
particularly grueling miles to the donna
party's journey
and just when it appeared things
couldn't get
any worse snow began to fall earlier
than expected
in the sierra nevada mountains and
the group was faced with the frightening
possibility
that they may be forced to spend winter
in the great outdoors
at the mercy of the elements but
hey at least the snow meant they no
longer had to worry about those depleted
water supplies
tensions within the group were
understandably high
and a fight broke out between james reed
and another member
who reed ultimately ended up stabbing to
death
the party was outraged and many called
for reed
to be hanged to be fair i imagine they'd
all been waiting for an excuse to hang
him
a long time before he added murder to
his repertoire of bad decisions
but still it didn't help fortunately for
reid
his wife convinced the party to spare
his life
and instead he was banished from the
group and
forced to ride off to complete the
journey alone
which in hindsight was probably more of
a reward
than a punishment the bedraggled wagon
train reached a truckee river
on the 16th of october where they were
joined by two native american guides
who offered to help them find their way
through the mountains for the first time
in months there was a raised
sense of optimism not that it lasted
long
because george donna's wagon axle was
damaged
not long afterwards forcing him and 22
others
to stay behind and fix it the rest of
the party only managed a further six
miles before they too were forced to
stop
this time due to heavy snowfall by this
time
the donner party were the only wagon
trains still on the trail
and they finally had to admit defeat
there was just no way they were going to
make it to california
before winter set in the group started
to construct shelters
in preparation for the months ahead
hunting and fishing attempts were made
but with little success and with their
stores of provisions already dangerously
low
stomachs were starting to rumble in
desperation a group of 17 people
including the native american guides set
out on makeshift snowshoes
to try and find help this group would
later come to be known as
the full-on hope which gives you a clue
that things weren't going to play out
all that well for them
in truth the forlorn hope were doomed
from the beginning
less than a week into their journey they
ran out of food
unaccustomed to the harsh conditions
they became lost
and disorientated some turned back
and others grew delirious their leader
a man named charles stanton began
suffering from snow blindness
realizing he couldn't go on any further
he sat down
lit his pipe and told the group he'd
catch them up later
he would never be seen alive again the
remainder of fallorn hope
pitched up a camp and lit a fire only
for a blizzard to blow it out
by this point their situation was
critical
the punishing conditions were taking a
huge physical toll on the group
and they hadn't eaten for days they were
experiencing the kind of hunger that can
do strange things to the mind
nobody knows who first raised the idea
of sacrificing one of the group
to eat but it seems someone did
because on christmas eve 1846
the members of fallorn hope began
drawing lots
a man called patrick dolan drew the
literal short straw
but to his very great relief his friends
couldn't bring themselves to
butcher him like a pig they were hungry
but not that hungry at least
not yet as it happened dolan died
the very next day without any help from
his friends
as did another member of the group the
surviving members of fallorn hope
managed to resist
the pull of fresh meat for around about
a day
before finally tucking into the grimaced
christmas dinner on record
right after little chef after witnessing
the pioneers
chowing down on human flesh and hearing
rumors that
they too might soon find themselves on
the menu the two native american guides
decided
it was probably a good idea that they
got as far away from this snowy
hellscape
as possible unfortunately being the only
members of the group who still hadn't
eaten
they didn't make it far before
collapsing in the snow
when they were later found exhausted
nearby
they were shot taken back to the camp
and consumed on the 12th of january
what was left of the forlorn hope party
finally made it to the other side of the
mountain range
where they were helped by a village of
miwok native americans
the very same tribe that the two
murdered guides had belonged to
presumably the group chose to keep this
little detail quiet
as they enjoyed the life-saving
hospitality
of their new friends the seven remaining
survivors of fallorn hope
began the process of rallying rescue
parties for the survivors back at the
lake
but the harsh winter meant they wouldn't
be able to reach them for at least
another month
back on the other side of the mountain
range the remaining donna party
had also exhausted their food supplies
cattle
horses and even pet dogs had all been
consumed
the remaining animal bones had been
boiled in a macabre gruel
that had little nutritional value things
had gotten
so bad they resorted to eating tree bark
pine cones mice and leather
as far as diets go it wasn't great
and soon enough people started to
succumb to starvation
as each member of the group passed away
they were solemnly buried deep beneath
the snow
but much as it had been with forlorn
hope
the survivors simply couldn't stop
thinking about
all that meat conveniently stored in an
all-natural deep freeze just a few
meters away
eventually the inevitable happened one
of the pioneers
patrick breen began keeping a diary as
events descended into the realm of
nightmares
he is one of the more famous excerpts
mrs murphy said here yesterday that she
thought she would commence on milt
and eat him i don't think that she has
done so yet
it is distressing patrick breen didn't
know it at the time
but the first rescue party would arrive
just two
days after he wrote this diary entry
when the first rescuers arrived at the
camp
they found it in disarray and believed
it to be empty
until skeletal apparitions began
emerging from the shadows
in all it would take four rescue parties
three months to evacuate the donner
party
when the final rescuers arrived at the
camp they found only one
survivor remaining louis kesselberg
it's said that kesemberg was found
surrounded by kettles
filled with blood half-eaten human
bodies
and body parts boiling in pans
when asked why free oxen legs remained
untouched
he explains that he found the castle
meat too dry
and that human flesh was much sweeter
the rescue party accused kesemberg of
murdering tamzon donner
wife of george who'd appeared relatively
healthy when last seen by the previous
relief effort
kesemberg resolutely denied her murder
but admitted to cannibalizing the body
in order to survive
much was made of kesaberg's taste for
human flesh in the aftermath of the
incident
he was vilified in the press and in
spite of protesting his innocence
he became something of an evil poster
boy for the whole grotesque affair
it's highly likely that much of what was
reported about him
was sensationalized but for the rest of
his life
he struggled to shake off the image of
deranged cannibal
eventually dying homeless and penniless
many years later of the 87 members of
the donner party that set off from
missouri
only 46 made it to california
both george donna and his brother jacob
died at the foot of the mountain pass
just 200 miles from their destination
james reed would go on to carve out a
successful living in california
as a real estate developer and
prospector
in spite of the horrific events of the
journey his daughter virginia
seemed unfazed by the whole affair
encouraging family back home to join her
in the west
just so long as they never take no
cut-offs
and hurry along as fast as they can
sound advice i say
over the following few years the events
of the donna party and
fears over the outcome of the
mexican-american war
saw a steep decline in people wishing to
travel along
the oregon trail it was going to take
something a bit special to reignite
people's enthusiasm
for life in the west as it happens
that's something special
was right around the corner a little
thing called
the gold rush and when choosing between
gold and the small possibility of having
to eat your friends
there is only ever going to be one
winner
thanks for watching check out my new
podcast
random interesting facts available on
youtube
spotify apple podcast and anywhere else
you get your podcasts
link in the description below thanks